Group:
B, A, C! B, A, C!
B.A.C, B.A.C., what? B.A.C, B.A.C., what?
Group:
No one does hip-hop better than us! [cheers]
Julie Nkodo:
I'm Julie Nkodo. I'm a junior, and I'm artistic director of BAC.
Lucy Fang:
I'm Lucy Fang. I'm also a junior and director of BAC.
Julie Nkodo:
BAC is the Black Arts Dance Company, and we're primarily a hip hop company today.
Lucy Fang:
The two biggest events we have are our semester shows, one in the fall one in the spring.
And these are the shows that each of our members choreographs a piece and the entire production
Lucy Fang:
is run by our group.
Julie Nkodo:
Our spring show was called "Beast Mode." "Beast mode" just basically means going really hard
on something or doing something really well. And it applies to all situations in life.
Lucy Fang:
The first real step is choreography proposals. That is the first company rehearsal of the
year, the first meeting where everyone gets together. Dancers who have a piece idea in
Lucy Fang:
mind will propose four 8-counts by performing it in front of the entire group. After everyone
proposes then the artistic director, who is Julie, she gets together with her assistant
Lucy Fang:
artistic director and they try to select a variety that will help the show be diverse
and stimulating.
Lucy Fang:
Each piece takes about eight hours to learn. So you break that into four two-hour rehearsals
and we learn each piece in one week. So you will just have four rehearsals throughout
Lucy Fang:
the week. Then up until the show, every Saturday at company rehearsal you perform that piece again
just to ensure that you won't forget it.
Julie Nkodo:
Hell Week is really stressful just because every choreographer needs a cleaning and spacing in Frist.
And what that means is that they need to clean the little details of their
Julie Nkodo:
piece in a studio, and then they need to go to Frist and have a rehearsal on the stage
just to space out the formations.
Julie Nkodo:
One of the things that actually takes a lot of work is costumes. People are just like,
"Oh, they look nice on stage," but there is a lot of work that goes behind that. And our
Julie Nkodo:
costume chairs -- Marvah and Lauren Brown -- they've been ordering costumes pretty much
since the pieces have been selected -- so, they are contacting each choreographer to
Julie Nkodo:
figure out what their theme is and trying to find costumes for each dancer on a budget.
Lucy Fang:
And we really appreciated our lighting designer and operator this semester.
Julie Nkodo:
Oh, he was amazing.
Lucy Fang:
Both our lighting designer Lehman Garrison and our operator Dave Holtz, they were absolutely
wonderful in their ability to pick up the lighting cues and listen to the music and
Lucy Fang:
just be really able to tell where certain cues are supposed to go off.
When you're in the moment, you want to go full out. And it doesn't matter how many
Lucy Fang:
run-throughs, or how tired you are from the day, how little sleep you've been getting
because it's Hell Week. It just really becomes you expressing yourself, having fun on the
Lucy Fang:
stage, and really conveying that to the audience.
Julie Nkodo:
I love hip-hop. I can just listen to it all day. And the way that I express that love
is through dance. And it is just like, dancing is everything. It has made my Princeton experience.
[Music]